Hello Everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to West of Loathing.
Now I just got back from PAX and i did not mean
for this series to go so long between episodes.
And that's why I'm here to tell you right now
that I'm gonna be playing this to completion
probably a video every day. Probably more than a video everday, and probably a whole bunch of other stuff
But we gotta go to the Baker Boys Hi-ooooookay...
"You spot a small makeshift signpost stuck into the ground a few yards away from the road"
"and stop to check it out. It says 'FREE MEAT'."
"..and indeed there is a small pile of meat lying in front of you"
"You're so distracted from rolling your eyes at this obvious trap, you almost miss the goblin sneaking up behind you."
"He's wearing an old buffalo skull as a helmet, .."
"..which you have to admit, looks really metal."
(as Mumflr) "I gotta hand it to you, you nearly got me. Good job."
(as Buffalo Goblin) "Hah! Foolish human is falling into my clever trap!"
"Now you are giving me valuables, or I (wait isnt it supposed to say I'm?) beating you up!"
(as Mumflr) "You know, this may be the first time I've been mugged by a goblin."
"Usually you guys are more-or-less peaceable."
(as Buffalo Goblin) "I am smart like human! Why making things myself when robbing easier?" (Nevermind)
(as Mumflr) "'Smart like human' is a very accurate description of that idea, yeah."
Gary! Talk to this guy!
(uhhh, sure boss...)
ohhhh... convince the goblin of something. They're talking too fast.
...plainly belligerent and Gary starts to look exasperated.
(as Gary) "What a jerk being! Hoping other goblins around here not jerks like that goblin!"
(as Mumflr) "How'd you get them to leave?"
(as Gary) "Threatening to report them to goblin elders! Whoo, nobody wanting that!" (I want it pls)
(as Mumflr) "They're real tought hombres, eh?"
(as Gary) "They are so s-(*laugh*)-ssy!"
They're so SAAASSY! Indeedy-doo they are!
(as Mumflr) A bakery seems like a strange place for
a bandit hideout, but I probably should have stopped being surprised by now
(Gary) Bakery?
(Mumflr) Where people make bread. D- Do you guys have bread?
(Gary) Sure, yeah! Making a bread of cactus!
(Mumflr) Cactus bread?
I'd've thought that cactus would be too watery to grind into flour
(Gary) No no, not whole cactus. Just pricklers!
Alright! Thank you, for that
Thank you very much
Just gonna go on my way, and smack into
these bad boys there
Forage that one
Gettin' that Loco Weed
What does Loco Weed do??
You're just crazy about this stuff.
No, wait, I meant- because of *laughs*, not about
Used in combat to get more action points..
Okay!
He-llo??
Hi I'm here now
don't mind me perusing through your stuff
Hello?
These teenagers seem dispirited, and are trying to
drown their sorrows with big mugs of water.
Maybe they misunderstand the idiom
(Mumflr) Hey you boys wouldn't know about some bread that went missing, would ya?
(Markipliers farmer voice) Awww nuts! I told ya we'd get in trouble Billy!
Shut up, Jerry! Way to just blab about everything!
Calm down you two
The mayor just wants his bread back
Hand it over and the trouble you'll be in
will be minimal
It ain't that simple, mister
We sold that bread for meat to start up this bakery!
Why?
Coz we wanted to make something out of our lives!
Everyone in Breadwood is just bums.
Plus like, everyone needs bread right?
So we figured we'd make it big.
Okay, well no problem. We take the
mayor, the bread you made, and call it even.
Oh yeah no problem except for the fact that we don't
Know a dang thing about making bread it turns out all we ended up with was weird lumps
Aw that ain't true Billy the last loaf was almost right
Yeah sure that one was nearly edible
We're practically out of ingredients
Maybe I can help
*reading options* I've got an idea
Hell I don't know- wait
What is this... what is Mr. Cowdy
gonna do here? I don't have time.
I'm smart enough to cook a dang loaf of bread,
just gimme whatever ingredients you have left.
But then we won't learn how to bake ourselves!
Oohhh fine, alright then.
Fine, I'll think of something else.
I got an idea. I'll teach,
I could teach you boys what to look for. There's plenty of cactuses
and wild grains you could use.
That sounds hard and boring.
But you'll have a lot of different options for ingredients and what costumers want
is variety.
That's a good point. I don't mind foragin' if you just wanna do the
bakin' Billy.
Alright then, school's in session.
Alright.
You teach Jerry how to find the wild ingredients
they need while Billy works on figuring out a proper recipe.
After a couple tries, they manage to produce a decent amount of loaf of bread (I didn't hear that right),
and back enough to cover what they stole from the Mayor.
Ay, I got forty loaves of bread!
All's well that ends well.
Alright, thank you, guys
Oh, look at all your bread!
Aww, thanks for helpin' us.
Maybe you should go set up a shop down in
Whatchamacallit Town. Where d... whoa.
Alright, I need to go back to Breadwood.
HEY MAYOR! Oh.
Heard a "crackle". Forked lightning.
I'll fight it, whatever it is.
Ooooo ayy.
You wanna get shot? Aaooowww you're deaheaheaheaheaheahead.
Man, that thing dies fast now I'm too powerful for my own good.
Hey Mayor!
Oh look, he'd walk over a deal, so sensually...
Ah, yeast bandits taken care of, Baker Boys got 'em done,
library book, half of it, well that's a real bagel biter.
Oh well everybody mostly skip the words and look at the pictures anyway...
I don't remember what the voices are. ...and mostly just the bottom half of the pictures.
So that's all right.
At least the captions are there.
Logging permit not met.
Did you bring back the soup? I need five bowl... Soup?
Missing mail? Not yet, cemetery.
Welp, I am not anywhere near where I need to be, but I'm gonna go take care of it.
What is soup? Talkin' about soup stock load?
See, a campfire.
Campfire owners offer you a cup of coffee and suggest a round or two
of poker while it boils.
You can tell from the look in his eyes that he was planning to cheat.
So were you, so it's probably fine?
Deal me in.
Your opponent gets really angry when his four aces all spades
are beaten by your five kings (all hearts).
He grabs the coffeepot and stomps away, leaving you with an unusually thick deck of cards
What, I'm not gonna use that as an item? Alright, fine then.
Ooo, yuck. Ayucka.
Alright, got that tuna cactus.
What are you? Savory talese (I didn't hear that right either).
Eveeewww, meat. Oh.
Ah, hello. I hope there's another spittoon in here.
These lockers have been pretty picked over from the looks of 'em.
Alright.Well, that's not so bad.
A lodestone ring? What is that?
20% of meat kings? Aw! That's awesome!
What do I have right now?
Oh, just pistol attack. I'm gonna get meat games.
I don... I.. I don't know how that makes my.... games more meaty, but okay.
Oh. There's a toolbox on this bench, but it's locked. Uh, welded to the bench. Okay.
Gotta hammer and a monkey wrench.
Okay, I can hammer things, and I can wrench things now.
I don't know how good that does me.
Eww. Pool of boiling soup?
I'll just grab that with my hand.
Mmm. Using a bread bowl?
You scooped some soup!
I've got a bowl of soup!
I don't know how that worked exactly, but I've got a bowl of soup.
Alright.
I've got a bowl of soup. That is what it is and it is what I woo.
What do you got over here for me
Hello. A knapsack.
Ooohhh, that's where I could've gotten a cultist mask.
Oh, that would've been nice.
Good thing I got enough moxie to convince 'em all I wasn't an idiot (huh).
Alright, elevator!
You see three different-sized bolts on the side of the elevator which are very loose.
There's a sign that says "3200 pounds pressure required," and some sort of gauge
which currently reads"0," whatever that means.
Turn number three, 411.
706 867, alright. Doing great. Love it, love it, love it, love it, love it.
Welp, I goofed it hard.
Loosen all the bolts.
Awhh, this is just another math one.
Alrighty then, you rogue.
I got your number here.
Nah, 3290. Okay, wow. This is a...
There's a son of a bitch that's gonna be a son of a bitch. I can tell
by the bitchissness of the son that it is.
Daahh, yup. Okay and try that one.
HEY, OOHHH.
IT'S WORKING NOW!
I just guessed my way to that one, well I--okay.
Hello. What's down here?
Lemme cartwheel into there.
Excuse me? Where are you gonna take me now?
Should I be worried? OH more soup
i ughhy *chuckles* I just realized
Why is there a soup mine?
i dunno *blabbers*
oooo heyyy im not sure bghbizrjmh
ok woah
*sign says* MUNICIPAL KROKUZ TASTA BENOKKRO KUZKRO
I dont have enough keystones to be able to do this
Well at least I know there's something in here
So there's something to do with all this cell vibrato tech